you hear that that's the sound of
happiness right there
that's the sound of
yes
my name is george moats i've made it my
life's mission to protect what i believe
is one of the greatest expressions of
american gastronomy
the lowly and beautiful the glorious
cheeseburger
thank you i'm done here
sorry i'm not done here at all hi that's
hot today's episode is important
because this time it's personal this
burger is inspired by
the burger that i grew up with it's
inspired by the burger of my youth
my hometown burger i call it the chester
rauer
i made it up of course but i tell you
right now it's one of those burgers that
if my legacy as we all know right now is
the fried onion burger
this is one of those crazy science
experiments that i really wish was my
legacy
it's one of those burgers that i really
dream about
all the time always dreaming about this
i'm always dreaming of this burger i'm
always
dreaming about this burger people i
really am i'm basically combining two
methods
the patty melts which is basically a
grilled cheese with a hamburger shoved
inside
and a poached burger which is something
you find
in wisconsin poached boiled beef
let's do it that's what i have i have
obviously a cast iron skillet
and um i'm going to start by putting a
little bit of beef broth in there this
is glorious beef broth
you want to make sure it stays nice and
moist because the moisture is really
a big part of the flavor of this burger
a little bit of beef broth in the pan
ah [ __ ] and here comes ups because i'm
pretty sure
that at joe rowers bar in wisconsin they
cook the burgers in some kind of beef
broth and i know they put onions in for
sure
i'm basically making onion soup right
here once i have the
onions translucent i'm gonna put the
beef patty in that's a good size
bowl of beef it's gonna shrink you know
so you wanna make sure you're not using
something too small
so i'm gonna take a ball of beef i'm
literally just gonna press it with my
hand that's all i'm doing pressing on my
hand
to make sure i've got this thing pretty
flat
pretty even pretty large
i'm checking out here oh yeah look at
this oh yeah oh yeah
oh if you can smell this right now
oh yeah that's that's incredible
[Music]
look at that look at that you wouldn't
think that this is how you could make a
burger taste great
i'm basically boiling a burger in beef
broth i have a theory about why
places in wisconsin poached the burgers
i think if you were cooking at a state
fair in the turn of the century
and you didn't know if your customers
were coming or not you could actually
keep the patties moist
by letting them float in a little bit of
steamed water
and it kind of sounds gross i'm telling
you now you take this one step further
you add beef broth instead of water
and boom grilled cheese
we all know how to make a grilled cheese
you know how to make grilled cheese you
may want to stop watching this and go
figure out how to make grilled cheese
the way this burger actually was created
the chester
the guy from my hometown named chester
chester murray
my name is chester and so is this
hamburger and
he and a bunch of friends were hungry
after a night of partying
and didn't have hamburger buns so they
took a hamburger patty and slipped it
between two pieces of bread
duh hello chester then took it to his
beach club
right across the street that was 48
years ago and they're still making this
thing
and since chester brought it to the
beach they called the chester
you probably tell i'm kind of tan i
spent a lot of time at the beach
this is my happy place this is where i
grew up
we gotta flip this look at that [ __ ]
[Music]
what i have now is this reduction of
beef crease and beef broth
and onions oh yeah
and all i'm gonna do is watch this ready
i'm just gonna transfer
transfer the patty to the open-faced
grilled cheese very important open face
grilled cheese
i'm going to add these onions on top
because holy crap those look good
oh my goodness oh god
oh [ __ ] she just did me to do that
i really didn't mean to do that oh god
look at that
okay it's a patty milk sure why not but
it's a very simple patty that you can
make at home without rye bread and swiss
cheese and all that [ __ ]
look at that
[Laughter]
i love this the patty melt
the hamburger for people who forgot to
buy burger buns
oh it's still pink in the middle oh [ __ ]
it's hot
stuff
oh
oh my god that's delicious
it's delicious and all those ingredients
are sitting in your
refrigerator right now waiting to be
consumed
people that is so good oh it's also
evocative
that's the thing about this burger this
burger reminds me of my youth
i was a lifeguard and this existed a
mile down the beach the other direction
of the different beach club
and we used to run down the beach eat
two of these
and then run back i had like i think
five rescues in my my illustrious
lifeguarding career
i had to save on my first day i pulled
this woman out of the water
she said thank you young man and i said
no
problem
vomited all over the beach true story
it's one of the greatest jobs i've ever
had
actually wait a minute being a hamburger
expert might top that
see on the next one when i teach you how
to
make a shrimp burger i'm just kidding
we're not doing that
you